Kevin McCarthy is the favorite to win I
bought 800 shares in Jim Jordan and I'm
losing all my money
because I was just like
it's not so much about thinking Jim
Jordan's gonna win but that the here's
how the prediction Market works you buy
a share in Jim Jordan for six cents if
something happens that makes it seem
like he might win he'll go up to like 15
cents and then you can sell the share
and make money off of it that's how
buying shares works I don't I don't
think it's going to be Kevin McCarthy I
mean I think there's a strong chance it
it it will be but I'm not entirely
convinced this is an alternate timeline
so Trump 100 could be coming because
everything that has existed I mean 100
somebody I fully believe someone time
traveled stepped on a butterfly and or a
bug and what we're living is 100 an
alternate timeline I'm a big Back to the
Future guy and uh 100 I would I'm not
endorsing this by any means but if I had
to put my money on Trump if uh Rachel if
you're listening can you put some money
on Donald Trump because I definitely
he's in there look at this two cents you
can make a lot of money according to
what's gone on the last two years
anything that's improbable is possible
you think that CERN smashing particles
is causing people to like manifest
reality and more wild ways the fact that
I know what you're asking is scary you
see what I'm saying and the fact that
anyone listening knows what you're
asking is scary everybody knows so now
here's the question why do people think
it's true there must be something going
on right conspiracy theory 101 rapid
consciousness fluctuation but the
internet also is probably a bigger
culprit and the reason for that internet
video the mass formation that comes out
of that let me get it let me get a
question uh comment in the chat
one if you want Donald Trump to be
Speaker of the House
comment what I'm gonna comment it dude
because I want to have some fun press
number two if you want Ronald McDonald
to be Speaker of the House one or number
two which one for me it's two three if
you want Donald Trump in a Ronald
McDonald suit no no no don't make it too
complicated ironically Trump would vote
Ronald McDonald
this is you guys don't realize this is
4D chess and Donald Trump is going to be
OverWatch that's right uh everyone he's
going to be the unity candidate all the
Democrats and the Republicans will come
together the Democrats are gonna be like
listen if Trump's speaker we have
something to campaign against and
fundraise off of and the Republicans are
like we just like Trump like how do you
uh align
um politically res yeah I grew up
um whether it's right or wrong I grew up
everything was the Republicans I'm sorry
Mom if you're watching I love you um
everything was a republican everything
was Bush's fault everything was a
Republican's fault as soon as Obama oh
my God a black man I voted Obama I had
to well liberal that's how I was I grew
up my whole life like that and that's
just how I was still who I am a very
open-minded loving dude I think everyone
has their right to live the most um left
as they want in their household or the
most right isn't one in their household
but in recent times with uh with kovid
and vaccine mandates
um people started telling me I was a
far-right extremist because I was
against mandates and that was really the
first thing that stamped it for me it
was never trump it was never
republicanism or conservatism or
anything like that and for whatever
reason just you know the left started
calling me a racist right-wing fascist
because I was against mandates which to
me was very liberal to be like choose
what you want and I thought I just I
found myself on like a strange side of
events with everything I said everything
I tweeted every song I made and I ended
up I'm I'm the only rapper that
performed on the Lincoln Memorial there
was like 50 000 people that's a crazy
thing I can say now I'm blessed thank
God but um because of mandates and covid
and lockdowns and these events that I
was performing at I stopped performing
in venues because of mandates and
testing and requirements and I ended up
performing in front of like doctors and
I'm touring with like Malone and all
these life is crazy man it's insane so
they said uh you're saying hi res for
Speed bigger I brought anyone at this
table would probably the people that
don't want to be in politics would do
better than the people in politics
anyone here who does it I don't want to
be I'd rather someone who doesn't want
to be in politics be in politics I want
to point out everybody's everybody put
ones in the chat supporting Donald Trump
for speaker no no I know I know but like
here's the thing people are commenting
about Trump is he's he's endorsing Kevin
McCarthy do you really want Trump to be
the guy what about Ron Paul you know
what I mean like if we're gonna start
pulling names Ron Paul or Rand Paul I
mean who Ron Paul is
here you got to leave right now you're
kicking you out what Ron is Ran's Dad he
is the guy you got it I don't know I'm
not a police no I I became political you
should talk about Ron Paul he's like the
OG the libertarian Guru of the day and
his son is Rand yeah if we like Rand he
actually invented Rand Paul wow
manifested he's a doctor with a woman I
love Rand Paul Bush was destroying this
country one of the few people standing
up against him Ron Paul what a legend on
the Republican Party 100 and he ran for
he started a run for president 2008 Luke
you said at some point he didn't make
the ticket uh I think did he did he try
to get on the ticket that he didn't get
enough votes is that what it was well he
got cheated especially when it came to a
lot of
um you know the way that the corporate
media uh reported on him the polling uh
the numbers it was it was a rigged game
against him from from the very beginning
but he got more support from active U.S
military service members than any other
candidate that was running in all of uh
in all those elections he made the
debate stage and he did talk about a lot
of ideas that resonated with a lot of
people but of course he was uh pushed
down by the establishment and kind of
pushed away from the general public as
much as as they could push him away I
just want to point out that Hakeem
Jeffries has a lower predicted price per
share than Elise stefanik like there's
no reason to believe stefanik would be
speaker's house for any reason and how
Kim Jeffries is actually in second place
and people are convinced he ain't going
anywhere near that speaker Suite through
this site can I sell two Donald Trump
tokens for a Hakeem Jeffries token like
can you trade I don't know stock or
whatever these are you just you just
sell them out you just sell them and buy
buy yeah he's buying so all right U.S
currency Ron Paul was like huge on
auditing the Federal Reserve when he was
running and people I think didn't really
understand what that meant because it
was a hard sell and other people were
like no emotions the first black
president you know no more war like
emotional stuff and Ron was also
extremely anti-war anti-war for uh you
know for liberty for the first amendment
was pushing back against the National
Security State pretty much everything he
warned about uh has come true in the
most awful horrible ways so uh yeah not
gonna say look at this Rhonda santis is
the favorite for the GOP nomination at
this point I agree Donald Trump coming
out from McCarthy bad
these these Freedom caucus guys Matt
Gates bobert saying no to Donald Trump
think about how crazy that is a couple
years ago you defied Trump you were done
right now Trump comes out he's like
listen Kevin mcgarthy's the guy and
they're like no sorry Trump sad sad I
feel like you missed an opportunity to
get back on Twitter what's he doing like
they gave him he's retired Green Light
tired and he was just like I don't know
I'm better than that what even if I was
him I would go on I would be like come
to truth some [ __ ] I am less than half
Donald Trump's age but I'm around half
his age and I can totally understand
wanting to get the away from all of this
stuff yeah but stop stop collecting
money then stuff
money and be like hey I'm Gonna Save you
guys I'm gonna I'm gonna fix the country
I'm gonna do this for you guys the man
still wants his golden toilets you know
what I mean we saw his we saw his tax
returns he believes his own hype you
don't believe that he genuinely believes
he's gonna win and he's gonna run you
know you think it's campaign one and
it's it's whatever I think I think he's
winding things down my personal opinion
and I'm Maybe I'm Wrong maybe I'm
completely wrong is you do not as an
America First Trump candidate endorse
Kevin McCarthy you don't do it Marjorie
Taylor Taylor green is getting roasted
on on our social media for for
repeatedly endorsing McCarthy every
comment you pull up her Instagram every
single comment is like Marjorie don't do
this why are you doing this for Donald
Trump himself to be like the guy who
called me a Putin puppet and claimed I'm
responsible for January 6th yeah I'm
going to endorse him everybody's just
like what there's there's you that's
that's just like ending your political
career right there there's a problem
with the house as it's set up like
Marjorie in my opinion if her
constituents are telling her to vote a
certain way she should vote that way the
problem with social media is that it
could be Chinese Bots telling her to
vote a certain way so she doesn't know
who her constituents are which is why I
look towards smart contracts so like we
could represent ourselves instead of
Marjorie making the decision so are you
for a smart contract voting I would love
to watch something like that I want it
like as like a third part in addition to
what we have out and on the blockchain
I agree and we could do like a smart
content so instead of like we have what
440 representatives in the house of uh
Representatives we'd have like one
representative margin Taylor green has
700 000 constituents why don't all 700
000 people put on a blockchain yay or
nay who do they want to who they want to
support and then that the winner of that
sector will go to that it would be so
easy man I don't know how people know
about this I'm not gonna tangent off but
kyc you know your customer so each uh
representative with kyc we know who's
who it's impossible even if there's Bots
and other things we know which address
comes from which vote we saw it in real
time and now we know what's real and
what's not and it's probably a lot
harder when there's 80 you know million
people 100 million people when we start
talking in hundreds of as far as
Citizens voting for a presence different
story but as far as for things like this
we 100 can start that and I know I've
seen especially with my fans I've seen
both sides of it where my more um
Republican fans are like you're
welcoming in the New World Order with
Central digital you know with any
they're scared of everything anything
that's Progressive they're scared of and
then my more left fans are like
welcoming it like it's like it's
delicious you know what I mean I got I
gotta I gotta read this uh chip Roy
quote will stakon says chip Roy
returning to meeting with McCarthy and
others quote I am open to whatever will
give me the power to defend my
constituents against this god-forsaken
city
what who said that chip Roy it's amazing
great I gotta look him up yeah DC's uh a
garbage town full of garbage people not
every single person I'm saying it's the
politicians I thought that Charlie they
go Charlie Kirk talking about
decentralizing the RNC was really
interesting taking it out of Washington
DC movie all around the country so that
if people want to go bribe their local
authorities or their local Republicans
they gotta fly around to do it and take
a day off two days of travel and it's
like you can't just pop over to K Street
I don't really know all the terminology
around there okay streets like a
political Street where everybody comes
up lobbyists and then you got the
steakhouses you want to meet a
politician a lobbyist go to go to one of
the steakhouses in DC what's that famous
one I think we ate there before didn't
we go there Luke for a book signing we
met Bernie Sanders or something a long
long time ago yeah and then Bernie was
super rude and mean oh he was uh he he
notoriously is this is why Tulsi decided
to endorse Biden because you're out of
my way Luke I want steak and you were
like he was walking out he was walking
out he's a super mean Super grumpy uh
punched Luke in the face Luke flew back
20 feet is that why you're not hitting
self-defense
Bernie the whole time that was a joke
that was a joke oh yeah do you like
Bernie Sanders
um he sold out he he kissed the ring of
power he uh you know has a brown nose
from being up Hillary Hillary Clinton's
you know what he uh of course used to
talk about the Koch brothers plans he's
not talking about that anymore and
essentially he's a career establishment
politician that's playing the game
um and and the more the politicians play
the game the more obviously a lot of
people lose respect for them and
rightfully so if if you supposedly stand
for one issue and are saying that you're
going to help people with this specific
issue and then you Backtrack on all of
that because you want to make a deal for
something else that's going to benefit
you sorry you're a scumbag you're a liar
you're someone that's two-faced and
that's how politics is played and that's
what a lot of politicians do and this is
why I'm skeptical of all politicians
even when when Ron Paul was running
again I was even skeptical of Ron Paul
even said critical things of him because
we didn't always you know agree but but
that's what we're supposed to do we're
supposed to be questioning each other
we're supposed to be having the best
ideas let the best idea win and but I
think the more decentralized the more
honest the more accountable a politician
could be the better and sadly we have
the exact opposite of that we have a
system we have a swamp and even the
people who are claiming to drain the
swamp are becoming one of the biggest
swamp monsters a part of this larger
nefarious sociopathic insane pool of
assassin crap this is this is what I'm
saying if I was in Congress I say Super
Chat where someone's like Roberto Jr
would be a better speaker I would legit
nominate my rooster
like
here's the point
someone's got to stand up and just
basically say this is a circus it is a
clown show at first they were just like
we're not going to vote for McCarthy
we'll vote for anybody else and the
first vote they kind of vote randomly
then Gates nominates Jim Jordan
everybody votes all the defectors vote
for Jim Jordan today it was uh Byron
Donald's I'd go up there and be like
dude all I'm saying is I got this
handsome as rooster named Roberto Jr and
he will do nothing wrong he won't he
won't take your money he won't steal the
taxpayer dollars he won't lie he won't
he won't argue with you in fact he won't
say a single word to you I'm gonna vote
for him
hey guys put a five in chat if you want
Tim to run for Congress no six if you
want him not to although you got to get
into Congress to appoint Roberto Jr the
people who don't put us would do the
best that's what I'm talking about would
you ever do Congress put a buck buck in
chat if you think Roberto Jr would be a
better speaker than any other
Republicans Or democrats my question
isn't really do you want to do Congress
because I know you guys are all pretty
much like I don't want the power that's
how I feel but would you
um it's it's like such a strange
question man I would never say no to
anything except the obviously well let
me be with my wife so let me let me ask
you the same question in a different way
Ian would you be willing to stand in a
room full of swamp monsters who are
going to beat you over the head with a
stick for two years no I mean I guess we
need it and I don't mean figurative
swamp monster I mean like actual like
you know Swamp Thing and literally
getting beat in the head with a stick so
everything's literal nothing how about
here's a better one would you be willing
to let a swamp monster infect you with
swamp monster disease to turn you into a
swamp monster
I'm not going anywhere near the order to
try to save the world oh that's a tough
one playing The Fallout and then going
into the the crater where all the radio
radiation and super mutants
New Vegas yeah the new ones yeah
everyone yeah
the four there's the Giants incredible
three is the best you can you can live
in a radiated Wasteland for a little
while especially with a lot of rats
collect some bottles see a lot of fives
clothespins they want you Tim but your
answer to him yeah I would I would let I
would let the darkness in because I
think I'm strong enough mentally just
having gone through social media the
last 12 years and bearing my soul and
getting ripped down and remember
building myself back up you ever see the
Matrix when agent Smith tries to infect
Neo and then like he sticks his hand in
Neo's chest and then Neo sets turning
into a Smith but then like all of a
sudden reverses it and then blows up
Smith that's what it would be like the
DC swap would grab Ian and they'd stick
it'd be like
and then all of a sudden like we're
watching the C-SPAN and and everyone in
the house is wearing purple bell bottoms
and they're all like you know talking
about graphene um who is it uh uh people
are running and screaming and like the
Ian's are grabbing people and biting
them and turning them into Ian Rick and
Morty episode Graham Hancock thinks
every politician should do 10 heroic
experiences with Ayahuasca before they
take office I think that's while I don't
agree it's probably the most intelligent
thing a politicians ever said no it's
Graham Hancock he's a writer okay and
kind of an arc he's not an archaeologist
but he's like an adventurer he should be
a politician thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time